let me explain why I'm now in scrubs you
see we're at Watford General Hospital
with a patient who's about to have a
skin cancer operation but the surgeon
leading his operation isn't here he's at
another hospital over 15 miles away I
mean hello hello we don't have to see
tablets in operating theatres what are
you about to do you're going to have an
operation on a lovely patient Edward
you're going to remove a skin cancer
from his face and as this will result in
a defect on his face we have to design a
flat which is an operation to move some
of the tissues on his face to go into
the defect to close it this tablet will
livestream the whole procedure to
another surgeon with specific expertise
in this kind of operation this is an
interactive system where he can see what
I can see and Mark the operation and
plan the surgery over at London's Royal
Free Hospital consultant mr. Mousavi is
standing by ready to lead the surgery
Edward how are you feeling good you're
not at all nervous that your surgeon
leading operation is more than 15 miles
away
no just glad to get it done really if
you could magnify a little bit for me
get closer to the lesion this is my pen
which I'm gonna bring in this is the
area of the cancer which we're going to
remove which leaves a hole obviously
which we need to can't leave like that
okay so you're going to take skin from
the forehead to cover the area where
you've removed now that you've got the
markings drawn are you going to follow
those to do the surgery yes the
augmented reality system was created by
proxy me a tech company from the Middle
East supported by the UK Lebanon tech
hub yeah I mean I can see that
it's perfect the platform was first used
in war zones in areas when there's
obviously conflict and the local
expertise isn't available
this remote directing of medical care
can be life-saving
now it's helping train students at the
Royal Free and it's claimed it has the
potential to speed up the NHS referral
system cutting the time it takes to get
to see a specialist so you can have a
patient come in with a broken leg yeah
you could take a photo of it both or a
video if I wanted to as well yeah and
then using their send it to the right
specialist yes yeah ii hear loud and
clear how would you change this
technology to make it better so the next
level of improvement is going to be a 3d
camera which will improve the depth of
the vision do you feel like I do I do
because I can see it's very clearly I
can see his action and this is what I
would do in in real life the technology
is already being used in a handful of
other countries but próximas goal now is
to catch on with more hospitals in the
UK